when I first adopted minimalism in my
life I never imagined that it would lead
to a Cascade of other changes really I
just wanted to sell all of my junk and
get out of debt that's kind of where the
journey began but as the years have
progressed and we've downsized and
decluttered more I've realized not only
physical changes in the sense that we've
decluttered physical items but also
other changes within me in my life that
I never expected to happen so today I
wanted to share with you 10 odd things
that I have quit since adopting
minimalism and be sure to stick to the
end for my favorite one but also do keep
in mind I am no psychologist I'm no life
Guru it's just things that have improved
my life and hopefully will be helpful to
you so if you like content on minimalism
and slow and intentional living be sure
to like And subscribe so you can get
more videos recommended to you like
these first up is music with any lyrics
of negativity or things that just don't
align with your values this is something
that I never really thought I would
declutter because back when I was in
high school and to college I had tons of
different playlists for different things
like I I had a music for working out
music for resting music for dancing just
different kinds of playlists and I had
lots of playlists and when I began to
declutter I first of course began with
the physical items because that's where
you can kind of see a difference but
then eventually I progressed to my tech
my technology and I began to declutter
my computer and my phone and my music
was also something that I had to address
I remember having a conversation with
somebody and they said yeah I don't
really care about the lyrics I'm not
listening to the lyrics I can't remember
what song we were listening to but it
wasn't very good lyrics and she said I
just like the Beat of the Music I like I
like the beat of that song at that point
in time like I was like okay that makes
sense but the thing is your brain
whether you realize it or not is
actually perceiving that your
subconscious is perceiving those lyrics
so for example I went through my
playlist and I eliminated anything that
was degrading to women or things that
would talk about cheating I noticed a
lot of songs that I had on my playlist
kind of would make cheating like it was
okay and it was a normal thing and
that's not something that I want to
promote it's definitely a against my
values so I figured why is it even in my
playlist if it's not something that I
align with and two I think sometimes we
can just have music that reminds us of
things that we don't necessarily want to
be thinking of that just has negativity
to it so having reduced my music to the
things that make me happy that make me
feel good has definitely been something
helpful for me the comfort zone
something that I've noticed a lot with
slow living channels is that they tend
to talk a lot about rest and doing
things that bring you pleasure and that
make you happy and while I'm all for
living a life of purpose and doing the
things that align with your values and
listening to your body I don't want to
get too comfy that I forget where I came
from and that my time is finite I grew
up poor and now having lived in the US
for most of my life I forget that I
forget that the TV the refrigerator the
microwave or a commodity not a necessity
I share more about specific things that
I do in my video 10 ways that I
complicate my life to live happier but I
do some things that I don't tend to see
promoted on a lot of slow living
channels this is things like waking up
at 5am taking cold showers or forcing
myself to use my non-dominant hand as an
act of mindfulness gratitude and
patience I'm now a lot more
compassionate for myself and I listen to
my body when I feel like it's time to
take a break or to slow down but I don't
think it's good to constantly stay stuck
in your comfort zone when you force
yourself to do the things that you don't
feel like doing but you know would
benefit you you develop discipline and
once you've developed more discipline
suddenly you won't feel guilty when you
prefer to take a nap versus working on a
project because you could tell that
that's what your body needed or when you
take a donut in the break room because
you know that you eat healthy ninety
percent of the time and it's not going
to change your habits or as the saying
goes make you fall off the bandwagon
anyway this is something that I could
probably talk about in a whole nother
video like how to practice slow living
and also develop discipline so if you'd
like to hear more about that let me know
down in the comments below but if not
let's move on to the next one and I'll
shut up for now decluttering children's
art I really align with Joshua Becker's
teaching on how to actually teach
minimalism to your children and it kind
of stems from being an example for them
but then also starting young and
teaching them at an early age and I'm
very fortunate very thankful that I have
been able to come across minimalism and
kind of remove my shopping addiction and
my horrible spending habits at an early
age as an early stage in their life
because I've now been able to talk to
them about decluttering and I've had
conversations with my five-year-old
where she's told me I don't use this
book anymore I don't like this book we
can donate that one or she's actually
asked me like just the other day she as
she pointed to a little cup that I have
and she says mommy this is your cup
right I say yes and she says why don't
you use it and I I'm like oh gosh it
caught me red-handed you're right I
don't use it
so that goes to show you that when you
set the example she she heard that when
you set the example kids learn they pick
up on it and I think that art is also
something that I don't shy away from
explaining to them we're not going to
keep everything we can't hoard
everything and if everything is special
then nothing is special so I really kind
of set the example of we're gonna keep
something some things that are special
to you but we're going to rotate them
and that way they can keep a few things
that are special to them if they want to
rotate them they can but if not if they
get something new or they make something
new then something else has to go and it
kind of makes it easier there's no
battle there's no fight there's no
crying or tears about it but then at the
same time I'm also respecting that they
can have things that are special to them
and that's okay too I know that I've
talked about it in other videos but it's
just so huge it has changed my life it
has changed my marriage so it's
something that I can't not include in
this list and it's something that most
people typically have so it's kind of
odd in that sense
um TV video games streaming services and
other social media media besides this
YouTube channel of course this really
has definitely impacted like I said my
marriage my life so I have other videos
on that but some of the benefits that
I've seen from not having these
distractions is that I now love
audiobooks I love to actually read
physical books I basically take in media
that is positive I'm not saying that
social media is a bad thing or that
watching TV is a bad thing but we were
doing it mindlessly for my husband it
was definitely an addiction it was
definitely something that impacted our
marriage and so if you're struggling
with an addiction hey a pretty good way
to deal with that is to basically cut
out the trigger for it so removing the
TV for example if TV is causing you to
sleep late at night when you have to
wake up early the next day that's
basically what we ended up doing but as
a consequence we ended up having more
time more clarity more ability to do
other things that were positive in
nature one of my favorite things to do
is to listen to audiobooks while I'm
cooking while I'm cleaning so that I'm
receiving positive information that's
changing me in a good way and you can do
this for free through apps from your
local library like hoopla or Libby or
you can also get more of the newer books
available that may not be through your
library through audible I have a link
down in the description box below where
you can get a free 30-day trial of
audible with a free audiobook to listen
to my most recent read that I just think
is ah amazing it left me with chills on
my skin is the happiest man on Earth
written by a holocaust Survivor if
you're wanting to listen to or read
something that will make you feel a lot
more grateful for the life that you have
I definitely recommend this one this
next one seems kind of a simple one but
it's one that I notice a lot of people
doing and actually I noticed that when I
spend a little too much time with
certain people The Habit just kind of
creeps back into my life again and this
is jokingly insulting people if you want
less drama in your life stop jokingly
insulting people this kind of goes back
to the same thing of your subconscious
is always listening that person's
subconscious is always listening so
while maybe you really were just joking
and you thought that something was funny
and you didn't really mean it for real
you've already planted that seed in that
person's brain that maybe you did mean
it or your own brain your own
subconscious is now thinking you do
actually believe this about that person
that person is a slob or that person is
nosy or whatever it is that you might
have said about that individual
especially within relationships this is
something that I absolutely hate and
it's something that I still sometimes
catch myself doing but it's a conscious
choice that I try to avoid
differing compliments let me know if
this is you somebody has said something
like I like your shirt and instead of
just saying thanks you follow up with
something I had been guilty of doing
this for so long somebody would say a
compliment for something and instead of
just saying a simple thank you I felt
the need to downplay whatever it is that
they were praising me on or I felt like
I also had to compliment them on
something I recently listened to the
book The empowered wife by Laura Doyle
and I absolutely love it and one of the
things that she touched on is our
ability to receive compliments or rather
our inability to receive compliments I
think that this is kind of common
actually and I noticed it within me a
lot but one of the things that she says
is that when you defer compliments
you're not allowing that person to give
you a gift they're not giving you a
physical gift but that person is trying
to give you that joy that happiness of
having given you a compliment but when
you downplay it or when you brush it off
and then compliment them you're robbing
them of that opportunity to give that
joy to you it's something that sounds
super simple but it felt super
uncomfortable and just odd to me in the
very beginning but now that I've
implemented it I see that it actually
does allow that person to just give you
that love that they're trying to give
you in that moment this next one buying
gifts for people now listen I am not a
grinch I love Christmas I love
celebrating birthdays but I listen to
the book the five languages of love and
I realize that I'm Not A Gift Giver let
me know if this has ever been you but
when Christmas would come around I'd get
stressed because I had to buy gifts for
people and I felt the pressure to get
them something nice and that was
thoughtful and something that they would
love I hated the feeling that they might
hate that gift and so I would kind of
overthink it and being somebody that
constantly overthinks thing anyway I
would constantly overthink everybody's
gift and I felt like I had to give
everybody gifts and gifting is not my
lovely which it is not something that I
particularly feel uh love it's not the
way that I perceive love and it's not
the way to express love so Having
learned about the five languages of love
I realize that there are different ways
in which different people perceive and
express love so for example my first and
most important one for me is quality
time I feel love when people spend time
with me and Gifts is definitely towards
the end of my list it was something that
would cause stress in my life to think
about uh what am I going to give to this
person I don't know what to give them I
would always always stress about
birthdays and Christmas and so I just
decided I'm not gonna do it anymore if
I'm giving something to somebody then I
might give them an experience gift give
them something that is not necessarily
adding clutter to their home or just
give them money typically people very
much welcome money and that way they can
just get whatever it is that they want
for themselves and it eliminates my
stress having to pick out that perfect
gift taking commitments out of
obligation as a Christian and a
recovering people Placer I often found
myself saying yes to things out of a
feeling of obligation because I felt
like I had to or because I felt like I'd
be a bad person if I said no often at
the expense of my own mental sanity I
remember when I was in college to go to
nursing school I also had a part-time
job I attended a small group on Mondays
I went to bible study on Fridays I did
volunteering on Saturdays and I also
went to church on Sunday not to mention
I also did other events like leading
Retreats and just helping out at
different events and one day a man got
upset with me for saying no to helping
out with a youth group and he made me
feel like I was a horrible person for
saying no he he literally was just in
shock like no you won't help that man is
now my husband so clearly I have
forgiven him and we've moved past this
but that encounter was very upsetting to
me to the degree that I went home and
cried that day because I was already
feeling a sense of overwhelm and then to
have somebody have the audacity to guilt
me and to service without considering my
current state and what I was currently
doing or not doing besides the fact that
this encounter is actually how I first
met my husband I'm glad that I had this
encounter because it taught me that if I
don't respect my own time nobody else
will I have to be the one who dictates
how my time will and won't be spent and
I don't need to give explanations which
leads me to the next one giving excuses
when saying no chances are you've
probably heard somebody give you the
advice that you need to practice saying
no more often as somebody who has
struggled with people pleasing I
definitely struggled with saying no to
people when I started to learn okay I'm
gonna say no and I'm going to respect
myself and I'm gonna respect my time I
began to give excuses so I would say I
don't have time or XYZ and when you do
that those pushy people that really only
want what they want and they're not
considering your time constraints and
your state of mind or whatever it is
that you have going on they're going to
find some way to make that plan work for
them they're gonna say it's okay you can
do it after work or you you can do it on
this particular day and whatever it is
that you give to them that excuse they
might try to work around that for their
benefit benefit not considering your own
so I found that if you just don't give
them any excuse you just say sorry I
can't make it I'm sure you'll do a great
job they really have nothing else to
work with and for me this is something
that has just greatly helped me so that
I maintain my own sanity when other
people want things from me that I just
can't give to them sorry okay
that's it end a story no explanations
needed telling people my goals and my
dreams four-time Olympian Ruben Gonzalez
mentions in his book the courage to
succeed the version that I read was in
Spanish
that he loved to tell people his his
dream to be in the Olympics because it
taught him who his cheerleaders were and
who the people that didn't believe in
him were this way he could form closed
association with the people that
believed in him and steer away from the
people that didn't believe in his dream
he goes on to say that later on when
things got tough and he would doubt
himself and he did want to quit it was
those cheerleaders it was those people
that he associated with himself with
that did believe in him to begin with
that were the ones that would help him
to persevere and to continue I have lots
of dreams and I'm incredibly blessed
that my husband is my biggest
cheerleader so I tell him any idea that
pops into my head but if I have a big
idea that I'm doubting myself on I make
sure that I do not tell anyone that
could possibly give me well-intentioned
advice on why it won't work or how it
could go wrong because I know myself
enough to know that that alone can be
the very thing that stops me from trying
to begin with I'm not saying don't seek
advice but be careful who you obtain it
from especially when the idea or your
dream is fragile when it's basically
like in the baby stage where you're
thinking I would love to do this but I'm
not sure if it would work out and you're
kind of still doubting yourself on
whether or not you actually want to
proceed with it to begin with I imagine
my child coming up to me with a picture
of a donkey that looks like it was wrong
with their foot but instead of asking
them something like what inspired you to
draw this or what does it mean to you I
say something like it looks lopsided or
it's crooked I'm being well intentioned
I'm trying to help them draw a better
donkey but what do these comments
actually do to my child's confidence is
it more likely that they're actually
going to continue to try to draw more
donkeys or whatever it is that they're
wanting to draw or might it just
actually shame them and to turn them
from actually continuing to do that I
don't know about you but even as an
adult well-intentioned criticism
especially from those people that I love
can often be the cause for me to doubt
myself so now I'm a lot more careful
about who I share my ideas with when
they're in that small fragile state when
I'm already kind of feeling a sense of
doubt and typically what I do is I share
my ideas slowly once I've actually
implemented steps to getting there
Reuben's method is also a wonderful tool
because you use the knowing of who
believes in you and who doesn't to your
advantage so that's it for my 10 odd
things that I've quit since adopting
minimalism things that I just really
never expected to happen as a result of
adopting minimalism slow and intentional
living into my life I'm no psychologist
so I'm nobody to really give you advice
but these things really have impacted my
life in a positive way so hopefully you
found them helpful and be sure to share
some of your own ideas what are things
that you have stopped doing that have
helped improve your life share so that
we can all learn together and if you
want to see more videos on minimalism
and slow and intentional living be sure
to hit the Subscribe button so you won't
miss when I post a new video I thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now